et
l'arme colère embarras si les leaders
politiques maîtrisent leur verbe qu
expriment leur attitude dans les moments
de tension
leur langage corporel et ils ont phase
avec leurs propos et qu'elle est que
révèlent les gestes de ceux qui nous
gouvernent ouest hier à le faire pour
répondre à ces questions et pour
déshabiller en tout bien tout honneur
les valses macron juppé cos et marine le
pen dans ces moments de tension ou des
gestes peuvent trahir avec nous trois
invités bonjour philippe turchet
synergologue et auteur de plusieurs
ouvrages sur la gestuelle dans ce
langage universel du corps aux éditions
de l'homme alors vous vivez au canada et
que vous apporterez un peu de fraîcheur
dans le regard alors pas ça vous
parisien avec de la fraîcheur comme un
nourdine cherkaoui fonds spécialiste en
coaching de la gestuelle chez havas
worldwide paris et enfin mariette
darrigrand sémiologue et auteur de ce
livre sexy corpus tout un programme de
voyage dans la chair des mots aux
éditions le mieux alors je vous propose
de commencer l'émission par une image
qui a déjà quelques mois mais qui
éclaire un des phénomènes les plus
commentées de la vie gouvernementale ces
derniers temps la fameuse rivalité valls
macro ces dernières semaines la presse a
fait ses choux gras des pigs et des
tensions mais il y a quelques mois les
deux poser encore sur la mode de la
bonne entente
c'était lors d'un déplacement au japon
un pôle on sait la navy novation franco
japonaise et les deux s'étaient rendus à
tokyo bras dessus bras dessous ou
presque tous les deux premiers munich
nous l'économie pour vanter leurs
japon comment qualifieriez votre duo
départ c'est un idiot c'est un
gouvernement il ya plusieurs membres du
gouvernement mais le premier ministre et
le ministre de l'économie sans là pour
montrer que la france et dynamique elle
est en mouvement et nous nous sommes
dynamiques et en mouvement et le sommes
créatifs
on lance cette campagne créatif france
c'est aussi le lancement de la french
tech
à tokyo parmi ces l'économie en début
d'après midi donc dynamisme peu
mouvement et créativité voilà ce qui
nous caractérise
merci
on a pu lire des articles sur la filière
de l'arctique sur votre ligne sont des
fables voilà nos qu'un dit valls a
aucune rivalité
ça c'est pour les paroles mais que
disent les gestes et trahi style un
climat moins cordiale que celui
revendiqué nourdine cherkaoui peut-être
sur valls pour commencer parce qu'ils
sont deux là comme il ya deux et on
pourrait faire la séquence qui est le
mâle alpha qui est le mâle dominant
d'accord basset suite je parlerai de
gestion qui parle et vous le voyez bien
que emmanuel macron est en position
défensive fermé derrière ils écoutent et
le premier ministre rappelle que ce
n'est pas un duo donc ce n'est pas
égalitaire
philippe turchet oui en fait ce qui est
intéressante c'est de se rendre compte
que et manuel valls alors qu'il va
parler d' emmanuel macron ne le regarde
jamais non c'est à dire qu' il va vers
lui mais que l'on regarde subrepticement
la première fois une sidération du
regard il le regardera plus si bien qu
emmanuel macron se rencontrent se
rendant compte qu'il aura pas d'échangé
chloé miss se met en arrière et se met à
parler à quelqu'un d'autre alors
derrière ce croisement de brailler aussi
il ya aussi le fait que je montre
qu'après tout les choses se fassent
autour de moi mais moi j'ai rien à g pas
rentrer dans la course les gens font les
choses les choses autour de moi mais moi
je ne bouge pas est ce qu'on remarque
c'est que ses mains sont assez hot aussi
c'est quand les mains son hôte c'est le
dominant qui met les mains le plus haut
est dans un et quand les gens sont en
situation des changes comme ça celui qui
m'a le plus haut est souvent le le
dominant l'autre et collaborateurs ya le
mâle dominant qui parle le mâle dominant
qui croyaient qu'ils posaient bp qui
manque quand même qu' il manque quand
même en entonnant ses mains comme ça
here is the kills et voilà qu'il est
assez haut
alors qui pourrait très bien le faire
comme ça donc
et donc en face et puis on vous dit son
côté en retrait voilà il se met vraiment
en retrait en ce sens voilà finalement
tout ça ne me concerne pas
oui tout à fait il va rentrer un peu
agressif quand oui oui et d'ailleurs ils
s'arrangent pour trouver quelqu'un qui
va parler derrière lui pour pouvoir
tourner ostensiblement mais pour tourner
la tête au premier ministre le dos
premier ministre et montrer que lui
aussi comme unique pendant que le promu
se communique lui aussi comme unique
nous communiquons tous les deux donc
verdi que vous diriez déjà rivalité
c'est assez évident des deux côtés oui
évidente ça ou c'est évident nous en
marche tous là ils sont en marche tous
les deux ils sont en marche tous les
deux mariette darrigrand êtes intéressé
par le langage du silence qui est une
des formes du langage justement il ne
dit rien et il a son sourire accueillant
makroumy sur emmanuel macron parce que
je pense que c'est le nouveau type de
mâle dominant
il ya une passation il ya eu un effet
générationnel imsand est donc celui qui
va écouter le corps social tout en
souriant
aujourd'hui est peut-être en train de
dire quelque chose d'assez puissant il
semble assez intéressant non finalement
le mâle dominant n'est pas celui qu'il
semblerait au premier abord
et vous pensez que c'est une posture
pour le coup travailler parce qu'il ya
toujours cette question dans les châssis
est le geste travailler et puis le geste
de spontané oui il a une grande valeur
iconiques comme on dit dans le monde de
la mode il est bien physiquement sur
sous l'angle de la du fashion et il a
une montre discrètement son alliance
avec sam un peu haute
hélas non je crois que les saisines très
discrètement son alliance à distance est
connu dans l'est dans le monde de la de
la pub ou de la mode lorsqu'il faut
précisément dire quelque chose de cet
ordre c'est à dire du conformisme
classique et bien les mannequins montre
toujours leur alliance même comme
d'accord ok donc en fait c'est ça je
suis prêt de lui non jacques rose et je
suis conformiste je monte là je traduis
des fois que j'aurai je résume je
comprends d'accord non c'est intéressant
et c'est donc vous vous disiez quand
même assez travaillé la posture vous
diriez aussi travaillé dans les deux cas
où il ya quand même des choses qui leur
échappe parce que lorsque vous analysez
philippe turchet c'était comme une
posture très travaillé notamment de la
part de maquereaux oui le croisement
d'un trait au oui mais en même temps
le les changent de regard c'est pas
quelque chose qui me semble-t-il et et
s'ils travaillaient que ça il ya quelque
chose de inconsciemment je ne veux pas
le regarder je ne veux plus d'importance
donc donc je regarde ailleurs
alors on a vu valls manuel valls dans un
moment assez détendu fans d'humour
d'apparence à d'après ce qu'on a ce
qu'on a compris on va le voir maintenant
dans un moment compliqué très compliqué
pour lui ces dernières semaines celui
des tensions autour de la loi elle comme
riz alors comment gère-t-il l'instant at
il comme certains le disent au bord de
la crise de nerfs on commence par une
déclaration début mars à l'heure on est
au salon de l'agriculture où le premier
ministre est en déplacement en touraine
a aussi de nombreuses personnes qui
n'ont pas les bras croisés si je vois
bien et il annonce le report de la loi
un coup de frein pour démarrer des
négociations qui n'avait pas été fait
avant nous allons nous donner quelques
jours supplémentaires j'aurai l'occasion
de recevoir dans une semaine sans doute
l'ensemble des partenaires sociaux
organisations syndicales et
organisations patronales les unes après
les autres et avec la mêlée rory et
emmanuel macron pouvoir les réunir
ensuite pour restituer ce débat voilà
c'est par le dialogue que l'on fait
avancer les choses mais je veux aussi
bien sûr marc ela la très grande
détermination du gouvernement à faire
avancer ce texte qui est utile pour les
entreprises
utile pour les salariés est utile pour
le pays voilà c'est un peu un défi pour
les spécialistes de la gestuelle parce
que faut dire qu'ils bougent quand même
très peu à il est quand même assez figée
certains disent qu'ils amassent cas
voilà et ça se reproduit à nouveau
quelques jours plus tard dans
l'hémicycle au moment où lors des mois
dans la négociation alors ce qu'ils
endossent leur haute cour le recours aux
49 3 j'ai engagé après l'accord du
conseil des ministres présidé par le
chef de l'état la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement sur le texte nouvelles
libertés nouvelles protections pour les
entreprises et les actifs cette décision
j'y reviendrai
elle s'est imposée car derrière les
appels au dialogue
il y a depuis le début une volonté
d'aller au blocage
monsieur chassaigne vous souhaitiez être
écoutés écoutez moi alors ce texte n'a
verse pas la hiérarchie des normes
il ne remet pas en cause le principe de
faveur il donne plus d espace au
dialogue social de proximité et c'est
quand même assez étonnant vous fassiez
une intervention sur la démocratie et
sur le dialogue social et que vous ne
souhaitiez pas ce dialogue social dans
l'entreprise auprès des entrepreneurs et
surtout les salariés voilà alors à la
fin il s'énerve un peu avant la garder
pour montrer les à son sommet la en
matière de gestes dans l'hémicycle mais
bon ça reste quand même très très très
très sobre alors il ya peut-être un côté
travaillez-vous qui fait du coaching
gestuelle alors ou alors voilà mais
malgré tout malgré ce côté sans doute
travailler fond on imaginer ce qu'ils
risquent ya un bouillonnement intérieur
qu on sent quand il ya du contrôle et du
contrôle notamment au moment
de la séquence au salon de l'agriculture
vous entendez un bruit qui fait
sursauter le public derrière nous bouge
pas il continue à dérouler son discours
de la méthode très précis son calendrier
il est contrôlé où il est concentré il
est concentré et dans la deuxième
séquence il est aussi très concentrée et
même ils neutralisent tout gestuelle oui
on le voit il pose sa main sur l'autre
main il est totalement concentré sur un
passage qui est quand même pas facile et
la gestuelle va avec savoir vous le
voyez bien il fait des gestes comme
celui ci en appuyant la voie et il ne
peut pas 10 des couples et voix et
gestuelle avec valls
ça c'est secte risquant d' un peu ses
propos si ce camp qui met la main d'or
du coup je le fais maintenant il n'a pas
fait comme ça elle l'a fait juste comme
ça comme ça quand il fait ça c'est quoi
c'est pour semer c'est pour se maîtriser
d'émotion une réaction pas si ce geste
vous aspirent au sur le réveil sonne le
rappel le geste de jean marc ayrault
jean marc ayrault faisait beaucoup ce
type de geste comme ça très verticaux
pédagogique c'est le premier ministre
qui parle et qui explique alors que dans
la séquence salon de l'agriculture on a
vraiment l'impression que c'est un
président de la république mais c'est le
lieu aussi ah oui ces résidents de salon
de l'agriculture président de la
république
symboliquement depuis chirac on sait que
c'est un lieu essentiel et ce qui me
frappe là c'est que manuel valls se
prend pour le président d'une certaine
façon là dedans ce moment où il parle de
au fond de la france du peu il est très
comment dire un présidentielle est très
statutaire il n'a pas du tout la même
parole que lorsqu'il est premier
ministre ou lahonce état limite de
l'ennui on a l'impression que ça
l'ennuie
alors vous parlez sage estuaire un peu
scandaient c'qui lafargue effectivement
dans l'hémicyle mais sinon il est quand
même une trace pas très sympathique très
très statique avec juste cette espèce de
mouvements mécaniques
je ne sais pas ce que ça veut dire mais
j'ai remarqué que c'était plutôt un
mouvement de premier ministre qui est un
peu à l'étroit
on sent que le costume de premier
ministre réduit quelque chose la
dynamique personnelle du bonhomme et
qu'on voit beaucoup plus lorsqu'il est
au salon de l'agriculture où là il à la
parole beaucoup plus délit
et on voit que c'est ça l'intéresse
parce que le café la gestuelle du pédalo
apparaître la gestuelle du premier
ministre pédagogue dans l'hémicycle et
une gestuelle un peu classique on va
dire d'accord et alors derrière cette
gestuelle effectivement très maîtrisé à
ce qu'on vient de dire est ce qui a
justement du bouillonnement de la colère
parce qu'on dit que manuel valls il est
souvent au bord de la crise de nerfs en
ce moment au bord de l'explosion ou
est-ce que vous la santé malgré tout
mais je sais pas en tout cas
revenons d'abord un petit peu sur le
salon de l'agriculture on s'aperçoit
qu'au moment du salon de l'agriculture
quand il parle du report de la loi
travail sa tête fait des petits
mouvements comme ça et ça c'est ce qui
se passe quand une personne me raconte
un événement traumatisant et d'encore c
tro mc
donc il ya un côté comme ça avec une
déglutition derrière et là je pense
qu'il est assez mal à ce moment là et
donc c'est sûr le salon de la culture
ces petits mouvements de tête comme ça
et quand on le retrouve quand on le
retrouve dans l'hémicycle au début il
attaque aussi il est marc aussi en ayant
un corps qui va de gauche et dominique
mouvement il
et puis il ya là où je vous rejoins
c'est qu'à ce deuxième temps où là il
quelque chose de plus préparés et là on
voit l'homme qui se positionne en homme
d'état
en montant avec sa main droite et en
scandant avec sa main droite mais
habillait les deux hommes mais il ya
deux mois les deux mois et nous donne ça
qu'on va parler de la mala qui retient
les autres savent ou pensent ça c'est
quoi ces rejets vous maîtrisez vous fait
que je pense que c'est un geste maîtrisé
je pense qu'ils ont tous comme ça tu
espèce de ritournelles gestuelle qui
sont des gestes qui leur permettent de
se calmer et je veux par exemple un être
humain pour se concentrer
il est obligé d'avoir les mains qui
reviennent l'une contre l'une dans
l'autre
voyez le chocolat chaud nos contacts
nous permet de revenir de nous permet de
se concentrer de se rassembler on le
voit on ne voit pas fréquemment le voit
tout le temps elle comme rite
intéressante je trouve elle parce
qu'elle écoute et on est au début du
discours et en 4 secondes on la voit
quatre secondes
elle crée une cinq fois des paupières de
manière metronomy tiens à dire que elle
fait venir l'information dans son
cerveau se dire qu'elle n'écoute
elle est pas simplement là on attendant
que ça se passe et le fait sa loi qui va
oui tout à fait et les courriels et et
alors ce qui est intéressant pour nous
cette voie c'est ce que ça voudrait dire
après chez d'autres indices
on arrête là sur valls voilà et
maupassant moi aussi et j'en viens à
alain juppé parce que lui aussi délégué
dans la famille je dirais que la grande
famille du j'exprime quand même peu je
pas trop de gestes alors un sommet de
maîtrise nous at il semblé en préparant
les missions même dans les moments
ultra-tendu ans s'est polarisée
justement sur quelques moments ultra
tendu pour alain juppé ultra difficile
comment ca qu'il réagit alors premier
exemple en novembre 2014 lorsqu'il
reçoit à bordeaux nicolas sarkozy alors
candidat un pour prendre la tête de
l'ump alors à ce moment là les deux
hommes ne sont pas encore clairement et
officiellement en compétition 1 mais on
le devine peut-être déjà notamment au
moment où il monte à la tribune il ya un
petit contact mais après ça se dégrade
nicolas sarkozy alain juppé
nous comptons tous sur la nouvelle
présidence pour redonner à l'ump un
nouvel élan et préparé comme le
souhaitent nos électeurs des primaires
ouvertes afin de choisir celui qui le
moment venu nous conduira à la victoire
vous me connaissez et je ne me laisse
pas pour ma part impressionné par des
mouvements de foule
nous aurons des primaires ouvertes et je
ferai tout pour que nous les
organisations de façon transparente et
efficace
voilà je ne me laisse pas impressionner
dit il on reviendra plus tard sur ce sur
ce moment sa réaction parce que cette
agression quand même des militants
sarkozystes qui leva en entendant cette
phrase primaire de la droite et du
centre
méthode d'abord le début philippe
turchet quand ils arrivent tous les deux
ça fait penser un peu à la situation
macro malsain voilà on arrive ensemble
on est déjà en rivalité c'est ça
intéressant c'est que c'est que une
chose qui est très connu c'est que c'est
le dominant qui a tendance à toucher
l'autre c'est vrai dans le monde animal
c'est vrai un petit peu partout et là
nicolas sarkozy la mène en le touchant
pour bien montrer à la foule que c'est
lui le dominant et puis dominant oui
c'est ça il n'y a pas ce truc là alors
qu'on louvre on voit fréquemment ça où
les gens rivalisent de jeu touché le
dernier qui a touché l'autre à gagner et
là on a on va passer du tout comme si
comme si juppé était pas voulait pas
faire 4 sarkozy encore donc il n'ya pas
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya ça aussi
d'accord avc ccc les bras croisés et
c'est un peu moi je serais pas là quoi
je suis pas là pour me battre avec toi
ici sur ce terrain comme ça il n'est pas
dans ce registre et sa réaction face à
entre guillemets la greffe militants
passés agressif il est dans sa bulle à
bordeaux en fait la zone du canton et
quand on est touché par quelque chose et
qu'on veut pas le montrer la seule la
zone qui le montre vraiment la seule
zone sur le visage qui va vraiment le
montrer c'est la bouche
la bouche est une est une zone qui qu'on
a beaucoup de plus de mal à maîtriser
les autres à la bouche de juppé elle se
contracte et puis on va le plat this
maleplate isma qui fait qu'on va voir
les aidants dubai ça descend là ils
envoient les dents du bas et ça c'est
une quelque chose qui apparaît dans les
situations qui sont en situation de peur
alors c'est sûr que la jupe est pas peur
mais d'un seul coup il est surpris et
cette surprise dans cette forme
inattendue et s'asseoir sur son bas de
bouche et on voit les gencives du bas
dans ce cas là la la zone qui se voit
non mariette darrigrand à pierre ya
aussi l'attitude d'un commentaire à
faire je n'ai pas d'autre sur l'attitude
de nicolas sarkozy à côté quand ils
écoutent alain juppé il est comme ça
lâche pas des mac oms a croisé un peu
sélect connaissent bien donc il sait
très bien ce qui va gêner alain juppé
qui est un grand affectif et comme tous
les grands effectifs qui ne veulent pas
rompre l'armure et montrer leurs
émotions il se raidit c'est un homme
droit dans ses bottes comme commencé
mais sarkozy tu sais très bien ce qu'il
faut faire pour le titiller l'énervé le
faire sortir un petit peu de passes que
le ce qui est fascinant avec alain juppé
c'est quand l'affect sort de la de la
cuirasse
donc on sent que sarkozy est aux aguets
et alain juppé est objectivement atteint
quand même par ce qui se passe et ce qui
m'intéresse là c'est le mot foule
il est l'homme seul devant la foule tout
d'un coup c'est à dire le contraire de
l'homme politique qui veut plaire
l'homme politique est celui qui va
mobiliser l'énergie collective en même
temps bon comme c'est retransmis on peut
toujours être contre une partie de la
foule pour parler à l'autre partie de la
foule derrière sa télé fâchez pas ses
idées dans ce calcul là c'est vraiment
très rare que les hommes politiques
traitent en quelque sorte les français
parce que c'est une sifflets de la foule
est un mot très négatif moi j'ai deux
remarques
d'abord premièrement ce n'est pas la
première fois que dans cette famille
politique on se fait siffler par ses
militants oui nicolas sarkozy lui-même
s'était fait siffler en 95 97 l époque
le président du mouvement était alain
juppé philippe seguin a eu un autre
traitement de qui était une acclamation
à chirac chirac chirac sait que
récupérer il réagit bien toi qui ne cède
pas il tout en conviction il y aura des
primaires avec à droite et le centre
c'est ça qui voulait faire passer comme
message
sarkozy n'en veut pas ils l'imposent
mais ces moments là ville chercher c'est
que voilà il a quand même c'est bien sûr
s'ils ont un peu cette petite réaction
un peu de peur parce que bon bien aidé
il a l'air d'être préparé c'est ça ici
il réagit bien et bien il le dit je n'ai
pas l'habitude de me faire
manipulés par une foule et d'ailleurs
s'il ya parmi la droite estime kapa la
droite et le centre
il fera pas les primaires ils ont
traduit à l'extérieur alors vous vous
évoquez philippe turchet quand même à
même si on le voit effectivement d'eric
cette gestuelle enfin je sais pas ce que
ça veut dire là il s et georges frêche
c'est jusqu'en de mon truc enfin bon
voilà je suis droit dans mes bottes ça
en même temps ils laissent quand même
transparaître de l'émotion un peu de
peur dites vous il ya un autre moment
emblématique où alain juppé se laisse
gagner par l'émotion c'est juste avant
cette séquence fin 2014 donc
l'ex-premier ministre longtemps
impopulaire en faut s'en souvenir on est
encore là dans le dans le storytelling
du jupe est impopulaire est bien
découvre qu'il a séduit le public de
france 2 pendant l'émission des paroles
et des actes et là attention climax de
l'émotion à l'issue de cette
intervention de la part des français qui
ont regardé cette émission
ce chiffre monte à 61 % des français qui
disent oui à la gpe ferait un bon
président pour la france
bon il reste un dernier indicateur je
retiens c'est la bonne opinion non au
contraire effectivement 60% en début
d'émission 68% à la fin des missions
dont la vue qu'en terme de traits
d'image qui était accolé l'ensemble est
en vain évolutions et innovations
positive le regard global à l'égard
d'alain juppé a évolué positivement
alain juppé est-ce que vous souhaitez
réagir merci merci aux françaises et aux
français sur dix en continu vous pouvez
peut-être vous avez l'air et mieux oui
un peu mais sont jamais remercié le
journaliste a encore du chemin à faire
notre jean daniel jeanneret ambiance et
les français voient là et là
effectivement on l'entend même à savoir
il a la voix un peu même complètement
nouvelle et il dit peu de mots vous qui
vous intéressent aussi aux mots mariette
darrigrand économes etc oui parce qu'il
a vraiment objectivement je crois du mal
à parler il est vraiment ému il est
vraiment touchés et donc ça dit quand
même beaucoup de choses sur le besoin
d'amour de ses grandes animaux
politiques je crois que s'ils sont ils
ont un côté rock star il faut absolument
être aimé et la vie politique dans
laquelle nous sommes en france avec
cette fichue élection présidentielle qui
est une sorte de casting extraordinaire
qui se fait au final depuis quelques
années quand même sur des critères
affectifs jeunes aiment bien
les sympathiques il est sympa et va être
donc juppé sait que c'est sa carte aussi
un il s'il est élu en 2017 ce sera parce
qu'il représentera quelque chose comme
une sorte de père de la nation n'est
souvent que voilà juppé il est aimé les
populaires va pas refaire d'autres
émissions qu'on a fait ici mais
justement parce qu'il n'est pas dans
l'affect
oui je crois que c'est un paradoxe en
fait elle est quand même c'est un grand
affectif pour moi enfin en toi là mais
qui connaît très bien les règles du jeu
eux qui a été à bonne école et qui par
ailleurs est un maître du langage aussi
donc très vite il se rattrape en disant
merci fille de salle son petit job sur
les journalistes
oui mais bien sûr oui ça c'est du vrai
juppé c'est le maximum qui peut faire en
termes de d'affect il l'a fait on a
gardé leur longueur parce que pendant qu
effectivement le politologue par louis
jean sur lui dans l'élite en attente
il ya un peu dit qu'est ce qui va se
passer et puis vous voyez défiler 20 ans
de traversée du désert dissolution au
canada etc etc et là pour la première
fois en tout cas une étude dans une
mission prône samedi que les français
reconnaissent la british ressaisi à la
fin effectivement à la petite blague il
se ressaisit donc il reprend le animal
politique il reprend le contrôle mais en
même temps à la question qui se pose et
je vais vous la poser si philippe furger
ces mois là on sent qu'il est ému en
même temps jouer de l'émotion ça peut
être enregistrés pour certains
politiques en matière de communication
on sait bien qu être dans l'émotion ça
peut être aussi quelque chose de positif
et ce qui la contrôlent l'émotion et ce
qu'il en joue comment ils gèrent cette
émotion
si vous allez dans une émission chez
fogiel sur le divan là vous faites c'est
préparer c'est travailler il ya la
petite l'arbre qui tombe et que ces
taxes à la s'était pas préparé c'est là
où c'est intéressant sur le queen la
retient il la retient parce que c'est
pas ça c'est pas son tempérament comme
je le disais c'est le maximum qui peut
faire c maximum vous êtes d'accord
philippe turchet en fait oui la question
de est ce que c'est une vraie émotion
c'est une question qui se pose toujours
et moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est par là à
la voir il est quand même vraiment élu
il est vraiment ému et la corse on
regarde la paix quand on est aux viandes
qui parler et quand on regarde le visage
je pense qu'on peut le dire aussi alors
à quoi on va le voir vous allez voir son
visage dissymétrique et sa partie gauche
du visage est beaucoup plus ouverte et
ce qui est drôle c'est qu'on s'aperçoit
que il se met à crier des paupières de
manière dissymétrique oui c'est à dire
que ça coûte sa paupière gauche
même par moments de cligner l'oeil droit
kling beaucoup plus ça veut dire quoi il
se passer quand on retient ses émotions
donc pour pas basculer dans l'émotionnel
il est obligé de se mettre en situation
de contrôle et ne pas montrer son
émotion justement et on voit la scène
aussi bien les 10me traits du visage que
la dissymétrie du clignement de paupière
il ya même des moments le gauche ne
cligne plus et l'oeil droit
clean tout simplement qu'il est vraiment
simple dans la rétention c'est
scientifiquement démontrée dans la
rétention des émotions alors moment de
rétention des émotions moments très
difficiles aussi mais douloureux on va
en venir aux moments vécus par
emmanuelle cosse épouse de denis baupin
au lendemain des accusations de
harcèlement et d'agressions sexuelles
portées contre son conjoint par des
femmes
alors je le rappelle des femmes membres
de lv parti qui a dirigé emmanuelle
cosse pendant deux ans dans ces
situations particulièrement compliqué
alors je précise qu'à ce moment là il
s'agit de la première prise de parole
des manières écosse après les
révélations 2 france inter et de
mediapart
est-ce que vous sauviez je vais déjà
vous dire les choses assez simplement
j'ai été très touché en tant que femme
en tant que company en tant que maire et
aussi en tant que ministre parce que les
questions de violence faite aux femmes
c'est pour moi quelque chose qui est
inhérent à mon combat politique depuis
très longtemps et que j'aie jamais
transigé avec ça je n'ai jamais fait et
j'ai été saisi j'ai appris comme vous
hier ses accusations d'harcèlement et je
vais vous dire franchement là dessus il
n'y a pas à transiger c'est à dire que
on parle de faits qui sont d'une extrême
gravité
et si ces faits sont avérés il faut que
ça soit réglé devant la justice et si
ces faits ne sont pas avérés il faut
aussi que ça soit réglé devant la
justice il n'y a pas d'autres questions
il n'y a pas d'autre choix et je le dis
ici et en tant que femme et en tant que
ministre
et puisque vous me posez la question est
ce que vous étiez au courant lui est ce
que vous sauviez j'ai été secrétaire
nationale d'europe écologie pendant deux
ans je n'ai jamais été saisie à aucun
moment de signalements sur des faits de
harcèlement sexuel ou d'agression
sexuelle l'accumulation des témoignages
on a plusieurs ne vous a pas troublé non
non je n'ai pas troubler si c'est votre
question est de savoir si j'ai confiance
en mon conjoint oui lol
voilà j'ai confiance en mon conjoint dit
elle c'est très très court voilà c'est
la fin de l'extrait philippe turchet
peut-être une réaction sur ce sur ce
moment là les combats comment elle est
parfaitement dans le contrôle ou à ce
qu'on imagine qu'elle a dû beaucoup
préparé son intervention par et alors
mais elle a beaucoup elle a beaucoup
préparé mais on peut penser à avoir la
dynamique de son corps on sait pas si
elle savait mais c'est sûr qu'elles
prêtent crédit à ce qui est dit oui ah
bon oui parce que même si elle dit
qu'elle a confiance et c'est elle le
regarde pas elle revient dans son monde
et elle n'est pas du tout en situation
de riposte quand on voyait là elle
devient comme l'animal blessé le corps
tombe à gauche et le corps tombe à
gauche plutôt qu'à droite des situations
font revient sur soi et contre des
choses qui sont si graves quand on est
on devrait être offusqué si on est pas
offusqué ces cas une partie de nous qui
se dit bien ici c'était vrai alors c'est
dont elle revient le corps revient à
gauche les yeux vont pas voir et
entendre et s'ils reviennent aussi à
gauche
elle est dans une dynamique où elle dans
une dynamique où elle fuit l'événement
quoi donc quand on fuit à ce point moi
je trouve ça curieux fui l'événement
elle fuit les questions avaient fui les
journées c'est ça avec son rythme en
tête qu'elle adhère à la fin des anges
est confiant oui quel aspect elle parle
de son conjoint comme dans notre
extérieur mais là je pense que c'est
davantage du de votre registre que du
mien qui est un registre plus corporels
mais là il ya des choses à dire aussi
sur le langage verbal me semble-t-il
oui oui mais là il ya un cas
extraordinaire à l'emploi deux fois le
mot saisie j'ai été saisi
d'abord sur un plan émotionnel alors
elle emploie le mot pour dire j'ai été
saisi j'étais stupéfaite
et puis ensuite j'ai été saisi au sens
juridique du terme enfin je n'ai pas été
saisi jeudi je n'ai pas été saisi alors
c'est intéressant parce que là je pense
que le drame de cette femme se joue dans
le doub l'emploi de ce mot elle essaye
de faire penser calme et n'ayant pas été
saisi sur un plan juridique elle peut
être saisie sur un plan émotionnel
or c'est drôle parce que du point de vue
de l'histoire du mot le mot saisit quand
on dit j'ai été saisi par
j'étais surprise c'est en fait un mot de
toute façon qui est juridique il n'y a
pas d'autres acceptions du mot hope
autrement dit qui lui revient les deux
fois voilà elle voulait l'employée sur
le plan juridique elle l'employée sur le
plan émotionnel à servir la même si la
surprend que voilà est-ce que c'est
décalé entendu des rumeurs escaut bon ne
sais pas évidemment n'en sais rien il
faut penser qu'elle n'a pas été saisie
voilà non mais en tout cas elle n'est
pas dense vous dit elle n'est pas dans
un registre offensif comme elle pourrait
l'être et peut-être que des communicants
lui dirais de dans ce registre offensif
bautzen ketchup ou qui fait justement du
coaching alors peut-être tout simplement
parce que c'est un moment très très
difficile et voilà elle a choisi de ne
pas être dans cette posture peut-être
d'agressivité à autre offensive qu'il ya
des éléments de langage ça c'est sûr et
quand vous l'écoutez à la radio le matin
vous dit
elle ne répond pas aux questions elle
dit vie le tir à chaque fois elle le dit
vit bien et puis vous retournez à
lagence l'après midi vous voyez ça dans
la chaîne continue et vous vous dites ça
n'a rien à voir avec ce que j'écoutais
le batteur que vous l'ayez quand on
l'entend on a l'impression qu'elle est
plus en contre offensive
quant à elle avoir le défend et là quand
vous la voyez je suis d'accord avec les
deux intervenants elle s'effondre
jusqu'à se réajuster à la fin de la
séquence que vous avez présenté
donc oui il sait un petit d'abord c'est
un petit nom c'est un petit confiance
on voit bien que vers la fin elle sait
plus comment faire et d'ailleurs elle
regarde le regard de plus rien elle
regarde même pas ses notes
oui on voit l'image à l'écran là donc
vous pouvez préparer quelqu'un là c'est
dedans c'est tellement dans un registre
du personnel votre vie publique privée
et jeté en pâture
tout se mélange dans tout ce mélange et
puis il ya toujours la question du doute
voilà et elle le dit d'une certaine
façon de se protéger c'est de passer
d'émotionnel à la justice ça commencera
par la justice et si c'est pas ça ça
sera la justice aussi navarre dont vous
vous direz en fait si on s'est beaucoup
préparé qu'à la voie à l'entendre
effectivement elle est dans quelque
chose va se poursuivre on pourrait le
penser mais à la voir finalement pas
tant que ça d'accord il ya une
dissonance entre les deux oui je
voudrais rajouter c'est quand elle elle
énumère ses statuts en tant que maire en
tant que femme était terrain elle ne dit
pas en tant que femme politique
or je crois et c'est pour ça que son son
elle a un penchant vers la gauche c'est
que la séquence est aussi très difficile
pour elle
en dehors de denis baupin pour son
avenir politique pour sa valeur
politique il y a aussi une guerre à
l'intérieur d'europe écologie les verts
sur la part de la participation au
gouvernement illégal entre gouvernement
et elle a quitté europe écologie à son
voile a interprété aussi la séquence sur
denis baupin qui aurait pu avoir lieu
avant qu'ils auraient pu avoir lieu
après bien sûr intervient aujourd'hui et
je crois qu'elle est aussi une victime
d'une certaine façon politique or salle
ne peux pas le dire encore l'audi pour
vous qu'elle se vit comme une victime
ah oui cette posture un peu en retrait
c'est aussi une posture de victime vous
direz peut-être de la femme politique
victimes qu'on n'a pas une victime
oui vite oublié exactement et puis qui à
la fin se redresse pour par pleurer
vous savez c'est de lemond ça on se
redresse on regarde au ciel pour pas
pleurer vous savez quand on a envie de
pleurer les yeux au ciel quand on se
redresse et pour pas se laisser aller
pour passer c'est tomber et elle se rend
compte qu'elle est en train de tomber
mais même si ces méta fleurissaient
métaphorique d'accord bon écouter non
mais ça ça alors on va changer de
registre à en venir maintenant à autre
autre thématique qui n'a rien à voir
l'attitude des politiques dans des
phases de changement ou de réorientation
de leur image un peu arrivé comme ça qui
a dit que des évolutions comment sont
elles gérées en matière de gestuelle un
sont-ils en phase avec ces nouvelles
postures ou ou pas premier exemple avec
marine le pen sur le plateau de tf1
peu après le lancement de son nouveau
slogan la france apaisée alors une
rupture 1 par rapport au discours plutôt
traditionnellement protestataires du fn
mais ces gestes sont ils en phase avec
cet apaisement on regarde mon espoir
c'est la france apaisée
parce que aujourd'hui nous sommes
obligés de constater que le laxisme créé
le chaos et que l'autorité apaise que la
nation unie que le communautarisme
divise que le progrès économique
rassemble et la précarité llc part elle
jette tous contre tous
on le voit bien d'ailleurs moi je crois
qu'il ya une grande opération de
réconciliation a effectué dans notre
pays et si je puis me permettre je
partage la vision de raymond aron sur
l'état l'état doit être respectée à
l'extérieur et en paix à l'intérieur
a priori vraiment
c'est tout ce que le front national
exècre il était atlantiste et libérale
au sens politique et économique du terme
madame le pen tout à l'heure vous disiez
je suis candidate vous êtes candidate à
l'élection présidentielle demain midi
16h vous savez pas du tout ouvert et et
changer d'avis vous êtes vous êtes le
candidate à l'élection présidentielle de
2017 formellement oui je suis candidate
à l'élection présidentielle de 2017 oui
voilà oui elle est candidate bon dit
elle avec le sourire mais d'abord sur
l'apaisement peut-être mariette
darrigrand alors à priori comme ça quand
on regarde d'expérience dit
effectivement elle incarne bien ce
nouveau slogan de l'apaisement elle est
elle aussi très apaisé avait pas
beaucoup de gestes à la main je pas
croiser là sur la table
est ce qu'elle est vraiment apaisée
alors nous sommes dans cette séquence de
l'apaisement après la colère il faut
bien voir que la marine le pen était une
mère de famille en colère et à ce moment
là ses cheveux étaient un peu mal
coiffée à la été mal coiffée mais
c'était absolument voulu puisque au
départ elle était quand même assez jolie
femme bien coiffée marine le pen vient
coiffer qui se met en colère et la mal
coiffée elle n'a pas d'argent il va pas
chez le coiffeur une espèce de pinceau
là nous sommes dans la coiffure apaisé
bourgeoise alors je ferai remarquer
aussi la petite croix catholique là qui
se montera donc on est en train de
passer dans l'apaisement c'est-à-dire
dans l'embourgeoisement ça y est
maintenant on voit que le peuple comme
elle dit souverain la prolétarisation
est fait on voit qu elle émigre pour
engranger des voix dans une france plus
bourgeoise et je crois que l'apaisement
doit aussi se comprendre sur un plan
social et donc vous dirais que là alors
même s'il ya de la stratégie là pour le
coup est dans un moment de stratégie
politique réellement vu qu'elle est en
phase gestuellement là on ne sait pas où
était la vraie marine le pen à ce que la
vraie marine le pen c'est la marine le
pen en colère ou la marine le pen apaisé
mais en tout cas l'alcool à ce registre
elle comme elle à une marque à
développer les marques c'est toujours
une station ont créé quelque part aller
quand on crée quand même dans la
protestation et la colère mais elle doit
diversifier un peu le produit d'accord
alors marine le pen apaisé d'audi
marianne derrière il ya des stratégies
ou alors quand même encore un peu en
colère et on est quand même dans la
contrainte à l'apaisement il est un peu
contraint une nouvelle loi qu'on est
dans la stratégie en tout cas parce que
quand on regarde cette séquence en fait
il ya eu il ya eu son arrivée sur le
plateau elle est
quand elle parle de son retour en
politique après quelques mois on l'a pas
trop vu
et puis là elle est très main droite
elle parle beaucoup à une main et puis
là l'image de la france apaisée arrive
et elle se met à parler à demain et
quand on regarde le ton de la voix sur
la deuxième partie de l'entrevue le ton
de la voix est plus aussi plus haut
perché donc connaître une évolution bien
france apaisée du moment de la france
apaisée à tel point que je me demande le
simple fait de voir son image très
apaisé à l'écran au moment où elle parle
de la france est blasé oui mais c'est un
effet de par effet de neurones miroirs
elle en rajoute dans la france apaisée
donc le je pense vraiment qu'on est dans
la stratégie politique et et avait
derrière la stratégie politique et alors
juste pour vous qui vous intéressent au
geste est là elle a toujours des petits
gestes qu'on a là et qu'elle a tout le
temps elles seront menées chez eux la
mère alors elle sourit elle en fait ça
peut être beaucoup de choses ça peut
être la séduction mais c'est pas ça elle
se recadrent en mettant une marge une
mouche derrière pour y retourner
vous voyez que quand elle fait ça en
fait elles changent elle change de
registre où elle change de thème donc on
se ressentent pour y retourner et celle
le fait très bien
pour resituer cette interview c'est au
lendemain d'un séminaire qui s'est très
mal passé ou du fn où ils sont d'accord
sur rien d'ailleurs elle n'allait
refaire la ligne économique sur
l'économique que ce slogan la france
apaisée est à contre emploi par rapport
à sa base électorale
là c'est vraiment une séquence qui va
pas durer longtemps parce qu'ils vont se
rendre compte que ces affiches là ils
vont pas être collées par les militants
mais que font donc il va falloir
purement de la communication et ça se
sent quand indiqué les candidats
d'ailleurs elle sourit si ça vous
inspire quelque chose elle rit parce que
la laisse pas mal son sourire la doite
mandant 7 alors que d'habitude
elle utilise des maisons des mines
renfrognées et fous rires quand je dis
elle dit je vais être candidate ça veut
dire quoi ça visiblement c'est peut-être
quelque chose due c'est une bonne
nouvelle
je pense qu'elle est quand même un brief
sur le sourire ou est entendue comme une
smiley quoique la james bond
l'apaisement et le désir de plaire
pour pour être heureux ensemble alors
pour terminer l'émission je voudrais
vous faire commenté c'est juste un geste
mais voilà il est très étrange mais il
nous a surpris en préparant une
précédente émission alors c'est un geste
de nkm alors nkm je vous recontextualise
le moment candidate à la primaire chez
les républicains qui a multiplié ces
derniers temps les déclarations viril et
ultra viril et va-t-en guerre alors
jusqu'à se dire je cite en mode greffage
de couilles avec des collègues jugée
trop timorée alors dit comme ça c'est
assez cache toutefois il s'agissait
d'une interview au monde donc en presse
écrite et le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est quand on la questionne sur le
sujet sur un plateau télé et bien elle
est un peu plus en retrait d'alinghi
vous qui êtes vraiment ces partis
intervient alors c'est un peu la fin
face y attend si vous n'avez reformuler
lambert par exemple notre phrase j'ai
l'intention de laisser le concours de
taille de zz omex c'est vous aussi
là bas j'ai trouvé ça long figaro j'ai
pu le dire mais je vais laisser passer
les rôles un tel florilège explique
d'accord au delà du langage fleuri mais
nous très bien compris et à cette idée
il ya cette idée que je pense qu'on a
qu'on a trop reculé et que voilà que et
que maintenant il faut y aller non mais
pourquoi de transformer véritablement le
pays faut pas faire les choses à moitié
faut pas faire semblant faut pas faire
des demi mesures
voila voila ce geste a pour le coup
c'est pas du tout viril et va-t-en
guerre ça ça fait très petit filet masse
sur les genoux à peu rentrer vers
l'intérieur et on s'est demandé qu'est
ce que ça pouvait bien vouloir dire la
cgi prix de le doigt dans le pot de
confiture
elle peut confiture de quoi delà de la
transgression dans la première partie
quand on parle des hommes elle est
assise profonde est bien installé dans
le fauteuil elle maîtrise on sa
gestuelle et c'est axa est quant à elle
sort de la phrase d'une banalité totale
on a trop reculé maintenant il faut
avancer et caetera et caetera et qu'on
rentre dans le vif du sujet elle se
remet comme une petite fille parce qu'au
fond il n'a pas plus de solutions que
que donc aidé par rapport aux solutions
non c'est pas par rapport au fait je
sais pas des petites filles à qui sa
maman à qui on parle pas mal non pas du
tout parce que je ne le crois pas je
pense que c'est plus sur le fond sur le
fond d'accord oui sur ses gestes ah oui
ou non mais justement au moment où au
moment où laurent rue qui intervient on
voit un double clément de paupières là
on sent qu'il ya une émotion forte qui
la ferait romain j'ai dit ça moi donc du
coup c'était du coup elle se rend donc
du coup elle se elle récupère très bien
en disant vous avez été chercher ça où
et puis ce geste je crois que elle
rentrera dans un trou de souris là ça
lui permet d'être plus petit par rapport
à ça et de se recentrer sur d'autres
choses pour pas rester sur ce terrain là
ouais mais sur ce terrain aussi de ceux
de ses phrases de c'est sur ce terrain
là n'est pas alex politiquement non elle
est pas à l'aise pour parler ici comme
ça de ça je pense pas que ça l'a rendu
tout mal à l'aise parce que voit sa
partie gauche du visage est très ouverte
elle et quand elle entend ça allait
finalement assez contente mais mais mais
on peut pas rester sur ce terrain là
donc sortons de ce terrain là et
recentrons nous sur les choses et sans
compte en ce sens un peu les paradoxes
20e qui souvent lance des choses comme
ça des axes de communication un peu
transgressif piqué après repart vers
autre chose oui oui et puis il me semble
que ça croise aussi disons le masculin
féminin qui est en elle
c'est pour ça que c'est peut-être
l'enfance qui revient là parce que c'est
une c'est une héritière du gaullisme
elle a été une petite fille avec un
grand père etc
allait elle vient de ça elle a toujours
tenu cela jusqu'à maintenant et puis
elle a lâché quelque chose elle a lâché
ses cheveux là il ya vraiment un signe
très fort et ali valley est allé mais
elle n'est pas une a dit mme morano elle
n'est pas marine le pen elle n'est pas
martine aubry essaie dé rennes n'est pas
une femme qui est facilement masculine
parce que elle a ce physique quand même
de d'actrice tchékhovienne mairie attend
sur ce registre
mais voilà et elle reprend mais je pense
que c'est assez sincère et quelle envie
aussi de s'amuser par moment et puis
d'être un peu corps de garde il y à ça
en ncaa m mais c'est tellement en
contraste avec son son visage et ses
cheveux que c'est toujours ça fait un
effet incroyable un peu sur ce terrain
mais pas trop alors pour ta rien on
avait fait d'ailleurs avec vous que vous
même une émission sur la gestuelle il ya
quelques 3 4 ans et je me souviens
contre nicolas sarkozy bertrand delanoë
on est vraiment des personnages très
expressifs qui faisait beaucoup de
gestes beaucoup moins dans cette
émission à laon ils sont plus dans la
dans la retenue pourtant on a cherché
des gestes expressifs
c'est quoi c'est l'époque qui a changé
c'est des personnages qui sont plus ou
plus sous contrôle je sais pas si vous
avez un petit mot même si vous deviez
pas forcément la vie politique française
tous les jours philippe turchet non mais
je suis toujours frappé moi quand je
regarde des émissions de télé qui
reviennent de loin là quand on voit de
gauche quand toi mitterrand giscard
chirac on s'aperçoit que au fil du temps
le corset pure et que les stratèges
amène des stratégies qui veulent que le
corps la ligne du corps en face - et on
s'aperçoit que les corps sont beaucoup
plus contrôler qu'ils ne l'étaient et
qu'il faut aller chercher beaucoup plus
dans le détail maintenant ce qu'on
voyait à très gros traits il ya mais il
y à régater en tout cas en quarante ans
ça donne c'est aussi de la communication
pour le coup d'être dans quelque chose
de plus épuré depuis un an avant oui
vous n'avez plus de tribun la gestuelle
aller avec la gouaille le dynamisme dans
les meetings de la campagne
présidentielle la gestuelle beaucoup
moins c'est beaucoup plus lisse et ses
lycées par rapport à la télévision pour
que ça ne renvoie pas une mauvaise image
et donc il ya excès et du coup on
devient insipide des savonnettes un peu
insipide moi même trouvé quelques gestes
mariette darrigrand petit mois sur cette
évolution
oui je pense que plus il se glamourise
c'est à dire plus utilise volontairement
leur image physique et plus le record
personnel inconscient imaginaire donc
incertaine imagina un politique a un
corps comme un artiste un corps dont qui
était assez créatif et bien et est
tronqué donc je suis d'accord avec votre
analyse mais il ya des gamins de en
rouge kw à 5 soit d'accord comme les
actrices stars l'école des stars de
papier glacé bon alors merci à tous les
trois en tout cas pour ces analyses
voilà intéressante on va se contrôler
observer davantage dorénavant merci à
aurélie d'heure pasteur antoine carew
qui sont levés tôt pour m'aider à
préparer cette émission merci à bien
gêné par eau qui s'est couché tard pour
la montée on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine en montagne et toujours c'est
aussi de continuer à pouvoir voir que
désabusé
c'est comme au cinéma moi j'ai revu une
époque formidable il ya trois jours mais
que boehringer j'ai trouvé ça
caricatural alors je crois que c'est la
même chose c'est à dire que le lait le
ciné beaucoup plus lisse et un jean
gabin du tout à l'écran ces dunes qui
sévit n'a rien qu'à tuer d'atmosphère